all right we're doing Shrek 3 today oh
wait snake three what is this the movie
begins on an undisclosed Island where a
group of laborers working for a private
company are seen doing excavations it
turns out that the island is being
converted into an ecological theme park
however their work is hindered when they
uncover a series of giant fossils and
skeletons hinting at the Island's hidden
past frustrated with the delay in
construction the workers decide to set
up powerful explosives onto the nearby
foundations shortly after they detonate
the explosives sending a gust of wind
and dust hurtling towards them after
everything settles the workers are taken
aback to find out that the explosion has
revealed yet another giant fossil they
curiously proceed to inspect the find
when suddenly it starts to move and
vanishes into the ground this is when it
Dawns on the workers that the fossil is
still alive as they try to make sense of
the situation an intense Tremor occur
then a huge python emerges from the
ground sending the workers fleeing in a
state of panic however running away is
not enough to avoid the Wrath of the
Beast as it quickly lays waste to the
entire area suddenly the ground shakes
for a second time and a huge dinosaur
appears the two creatures then engage in
an epic duel carrying up the island with
their massive size and power the end oh
no wait elsewhere a young boy named Kai
wakes up from a nightmare in the middle
of the night he then suddenly notices
the presence of a ghastly figure
standing beside him scared Kai makes a
run for it before tripping over and
falling to the ground the lights come on
and it turns out his mother Xiao was
trying to scare him here we get to know
that Kai suffers from a leg injury and
his mother trains him to gain more
control over his legs despite his
limitations Kai is very eager to visit
the ecological theme park and one day
his dream finally comes true when Xiao
surprises him with two tickets for the
theme park the movie then cuts to the
Mysterious Island where Xiao Kai and
other tourists travel on a tour bus
exploring the forest as they Venture
deeper Kai is left in shock when he
notices the giant python slithering up a
mountain he tries to tell his mother of
his sighting but she is not convinced
and assumes that it was just his
imagination shortly after the bus driver
Zhang notices two giant Boulders
approaching them from above and quickly
Maneuvers the bus to avoid getting hit
this leads to Zhang crashing the bus
into a nearby tree causing Widespread
Panic as everyone gets out they learn
that the bus is stuck in mud so they
have no choice but to push it out
together meanwhile Kai has to go to the
toilet badly so he and another passenger
go further away from the group to find a
place to pee however as they relieve
themselves the man is suddenly attacked
by a massive tongue which pulls him into
the woods meanwhile two passengers
Professor Jia and his assistant lay
observe the boulders and to deduce that
a monster must have thrown it towards
them all of a sudden some of the
passengers are attacked and pulled into
the forest prompting the others to
immediately Rush inside the bus Zhao
somehow manages to close the door but
she then realizes that her son Kai is
missing following this the monster
reveals itself to be a huge frog and
leaps towards the bus the passengers all
stay low terrified that they are about
to be consumed but just when the frog is
about to attack it sees Kai alone in the
woods and goes after him the little boy
frantically starts running and somehow
manages to dodge all of its attacks he
then hides inside a tree trunk which the
Frog cannot enter Because of its huge
size however when the Beast doesn't get
what it wants it pushes the trunk away
causing it to roll down a hill back in
the bus the humans experience an intense
Tremor and it's revealed that the giant
python has arrived it wraps its body
around the bus and hoists it up above
the trees causing the people inside to
panic and fear for their lives they
desperately hold on to the seats to
avoid falling to their death and see the
face of the Python on about to demolish
the entire boss that thing looks like it
was made with a computer luckily the
python hears another Roar in the
distance and abruptly let's go causing
the bus to Free Fall the resulting crash
knocks everyone unconscious a while
later Xiao regains Consciousness and
finds that only a handful of people
survived the brutal fall right then the
ground begins to shake again and the
passengers take cover behind the boss
they stay quiet and patient as the sound
of large Stomps gets closer by the
second eventually a massive dinosaur
appears and the human's cower in fear it
appears as if everyone has met their
Doom but to their luck the Beast isn't
able to spot them so it leaves without
causing much trouble in the meantime Kai
finally exits the tree trunk and finds
himself inside a large cave to his
horror he finds a giant piece of snake
skin along with several eggs laid on the
floor Kai then hears loud footsteps
nearing him and also spots a silhouette
of a monster from the corner of his eye
he quickly hides behind the eggs and
learns that the footsteps are of a
Raptor it is currently munching on the
unborn fetuses inside the eggs Kai tries
his best to maintain silence but all of
a sudden the alarm on his watch goes off
giving away his cover Kai doesn't need a
watch to know it's time to die as a
result the Raptor finds him and Kai
makes a run for it he eventually hides
inside a broken eggshell while the
monster continues to search for him
hiding inside of its food genius
suddenly the giant python appears inside
the cave and pulls the Raptor away
before devouring it in an instant it
then spots the little boy but
surprisingly doesn't take any action
turns out the eggs are of the Python and
it is now mistaken Kai for one of its
children this is because his scent had
changed after hiding inside of the eggs
while the python Grieves the death of
his unborn children Akai escapes and
exits the cave meanwhile the remaining
tourists are desperate and want to leave
the island as soon as possible a
businessman and the director of the
theme park Chen informs the others that
a tower is located at the peak of the
mountain which they can use to send a
signal for help however Xiao is
desperate to find her son she begs the
others for assistance but no one wants
to help her hence with no options left
she leaves the group on her own to find
Kai to her surprise the bus driver Zhang
accompanies her at the last second and
offers to help Zhao is grateful and she
mentions that they can locate Kai via
the GPS on his smart watch as the two
continue talking suddenly hear some
rustling in the bushes which startles
them fearing the worst they get ready
for the incoming danger only to find out
that it is actually the professor Jia
and his assistant lay all four of them
briefly celebrate their reunion before
heading out to find the boy the movie
then cuts to a tired Kai hopelessly
walking alone in the woods to make
matters worse his leg is suddenly caught
by a tree vine it turns out that a giant
carnivorous plant has captured him the
plant that viciously opens its mouth and
spits out a sharp Spike which barely
misses Kai's head but just as the Beast
takes its second shot at Kai the giant
python swoops in and blocks the spikes
simultaneously killing the planet as
well due to this Kai is able to free
himself and he is shocked to learn that
the python has saved him from Death as
the two stare at each other the python
slowly approaches the boy and signals
for help to remove the spike impaled in
its body Kai immediately gets the hint
so he gets some tree Vines and ties it
on the spike allowing the python to pull
it out after this the giant snake leaves
the the place and heads deep into the
forest elsewhere the group makes it to
the peak of the mountain only to find
out that the whole place is in Ruins to
make the situation even more Grim a
gigantic T-Rex appears in front of them
it attacks the humans without remorse
tiny arms or no killing them brutally on
the other hand Kai stumbles upon a
dinosaur feasting on a giant frog he
slowly backs away but accidentally steps
on a twig diverting the dinosaur's
attention to him however before it
attacks him Kai is found and pulled to
the side by his mother Zhao and the two
finally reunite their reunion doesn't
last long though as the dinosaur spots
them and attacks them right away it
manages to knock Zhang Jia and lay down
a hill before chasing Zhao and her son
the two eventually managed to get out of
reach by Leading the dinosaur through a
small hole which he can't fit through
however the mother-son Duo are not free
yet as they find out they have run into
another dinosaur who immediately chases
after them soon Zhao and Kai find
themselves surrounded by two hungry
dinos but even this time the heroic
python appears out of the blue and
knocks them aside saving the humans from
harm they then try to escape the area
while the python defends them from any
attacks but unfortunately more Dinosaurs
show up and attack the python all at
once in the next scene Xiao and Kai meet
up with the others and slowly head
towards the mountain the five of them
Reach the peak and like the others they
are also devastated after seeing the
place as a Barren Wasteland Jia is
shocked to see many Python and T-Rex
skeletons and assumes that the two have
a history of fighting each other
meanwhile as Kai is looking around the
place he is suddenly held hostage by
Chen who is revealed to be his group's
only Survivor it's evident that he has
lost his mind as he holds the boy at
knife point and blames everyone for
what's happening to him Xiao begs him to
let her son go but they are interrupted
by a terrifying Roar the giant T-rex
shows up once again and Xiao uses the
opportunity to save Kai they then flee
the scene while Chen is crushed by the
team T-Rex's feet following this the
group finds a car and Shang drives away
from the chaos the dinosaur hurls
numerous Boulders towards them but Zhang
is able to dodge every single one
shortly after the dinosaur leaps towards
their vehicle causing them to crash into
a nearby Rock knocking them unconscious
they wake up shortly after and notice
the dinosaur approaching them to finish
them off however before it is able to
touch them you guessed it baby the giant
python comes to their rescue once again
a deadly battle ensues and with every
passing second the T-Rex starts gaining
the upper hand seeing the python losing
the humans quickly come up with a plan
and decide to use the nearby explosives
to help it out Xiao gathers the dynamite
and places it inside the car she then
bids goodbye to her son before driving
away towards the battlefield Xiao
heroically drives near the T-Rex's legs
and jumps out of the moving car but to
her Misfortune The Detonator doesn't
work with their plan now foiled the
group is certain that they will be
killed but just then lay notices the the
gasoline is leaking from the car so she
takes a torch and runs towards the fight
intending to blow the dynamite up
unfortunately before she can get any
closer a flying Boulder knocks her out
damn so close at this point the T-Rex is
almost managed to finish off the python
so the little boy decides to step up and
save his friend through everyone's shock
he Sprints towards the monsters despite
his injured leg then with a good strong
aim he hurls the torch onto the car
causing the dynamite to go off the
explosion helps the python and it
finally manages to kill the dinosaur
while Kai is blown back Xiao and the
others Rush towards him and desperately
call his name but he doesn't wake up
fortunately the giant python has another
Ace up its sleeve pythons don't have
sleeves it comes near Kai and fiercely
Roars causing him to wake up in haste
the movie then cuts to sometime in the
future where everyone is returned home
and Kai's leg injury is finally healed
elsewhere Professor Gia and delay
explore the eye in for a second time and
managed to find more dangerous monsters
still lurking below the ground
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching